يرفض السيناتور بوب مينينديز من ولاية نيوجيرسي
الاستقالة على الرغم من
دعواتهم المتزايدة من داخل حزبه، والآن
ثلاثة من أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الديمقراطيين يطالبونه
بالتنحي،
وانضمت إليهم رئيسة مجلس الشيوخ السابقة جاستن الليلة نانسي بيلوسي،
فالتهم
هائلة، وإذا كنا في الواقع سنفعل ذلك
أقول إنه إذا تم توجيه الاتهام إليك، فيجب عليك
الاستقالة، فمن المحتمل أن تكون فكرة جيدة إذا
استقال بالفعل،
وربما تكون فكرة جيدة.
الديمقراطي الذي تم توجيه الاتهام إليه الآن
للمرة الثانية على الرغم من أنه يقول إنه ليس لديه أي
نية للقيام بذلك،
أنا بحزم  أعتقد أنه عندما
يتم تقديم جميع الحقائق، لن تتم تبرئتي فحسب،
بل سأظل أيضًا
عضوًا كبيرًا في مجلس الشيوخ عن ولاية نيوجيرسي، وكانت
هذه أول تعليقاته أمام الكاميرا
منذ توجيه الاتهام إليه، وقدم عضو
اللجنة المصرفية بمجلس الشيوخ
هذا التفسير لسبب ما يقرب من نصف
كان مليون دولار نقدًا أكثر أمانًا بطريقة أو بأخرى، وكانت
السترات والخزائن في
منزله بدلاً من قول أحد البنوك
لمدة 30 عامًا، لقد قمت بسحب آلاف
الدولارات نقدًا من حساب التوفير الشخصي الخاص بي
والذي احتفظت به لحالات الطوارئ وبسبب
تاريخ عائلتي الذي
يواجه  المصادرة في كوبا،
كما لم تقدم تفسيرا
لسبائك الذهب أو سيارة مرسيدس بنز الرياضية
التي يقول المدعون إنه استلم
عروسه بايمينتس لاستخدام منصبه
لتحويل الأموال والمساعدات العسكرية إلى
مصر، وهي
مزاعم بالطبع أكثر وقاحة.  نظرًا لأنه كان من
كبار الديمقراطيين في
لجنة العلاقات الخارجية بمجلس الشيوخ
طوال 30 عامًا في مجلس
النواب ومجلس الشيوخ، فقد
عملت دائمًا على محاسبة تلك
الدول، بما في ذلك مصر، عن
انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان وقمع
مواطنيها والمجتمع المدني والمزيد.
لم يذكر السيناتور أي شيء عن
الترشح لإعادة انتخابه اليوم لأنه
أصر على أن بقية
المحذوفين سيظهرون أمام محكمة
الرأي العام وليس بديلاً عن
نظام العدالة في رفير،
ويجب أن أشير إلى أن نظام العدالة لديه
سجل حافل من الحزبين
حاليًا  يواجه اثنان من المشرعين
اتهامات، السناتور مينينديز وعضو
الكونجرس جورج سانتوس، أحدهما ديمقراطي
والآخر جمهوري، لكن بالنظر إلى الاتهامات الموجهة
ضد السناتور، فإنها تركز على
منصبه للتأثير على مبيعات الأسلحة والمساعدات الأمريكية
لمصر، وأريد الوصول مباشرة إلى
المصدر الليلة مع الديمقراطيين
والمشاركين.  مؤسس تجمع حقوق الإنسان في مصر، عضو
الكونجرس دون باير من ولاية فرجينيا،
شكرًا لك على حضورك هنا
الليلة، تعلم أنك سمعت السيناتور
مينينديز هناك يقول إنه لن
يستقيل ولكنك تعتقد أنه ينبغي عليه الاستقالة،
لماذا نعم بالتأكيد، هناك
تقليد قوي في الكونجرس مفاده أن
عندما يتم توجيه الاتهام إليك، يجب عليك الاستقالة،
ستستمر في قضاء يومك في المحكمة، فهو
لم تتم إدانته بعد، لكنني لا
أعرف كيف يمكنه القيام بعمله بفعالية
مع هذه لائحة
الاتهام اللعينة المعلقة فوق رأسه